hey listen to this Donald Trump's pick
for education secretary Betsy DeVos a
billionaire has plagiarized some of her
Senate questionnaire for the
confirmation process can you imagine
that the education nominee is caught
copying can you believe this insanity
and to add to the sick irony there's the
fact that the only reason she even had a
ton of written questions to answer is
that Republican senator Lamar Alexander
who chairs the Senate committee that was
questioning her said we're gonna limit
the hearing to just one round of
questions so then a ton of questions
were submitted in writing by Democrats
and then the plagiarism begins let's
look at some examples here okay first
example that I will put up on the screen
for you here is Betsy DeVos a statement
in her answers quote every child
deserves to attend school in a safe
supportive environment where they can
learn thrive and grow here is a quote
from the principal deputy assistant
attorney general Vanita Gupta quote
every child deserves to attend school in
a safe supportive environment that
allows them to thrive and grow
stunningly similar language there let's
look at one other example that we also
have Betsy DeVos quote opening a
complaint for investigation in no way
implies that the Office for Civil Rights
has made a determination about the
merits of the complaint of course
guidance from the Department of
Education on the same issue quote
opening a complaint for investigation in
no way implies that OCR has made a
determination with regard to the merits
of the complaint we teach students that
plagiarism is wrong but we're going to
put a plagiarize er in charge of all
education in the United States of
America the amount of plagiarism
happening within just the Trump world is
stunning Melania Trump plagiarized part
of her Republican National Committee
speech over the summer from a speech
that former first lady Michelle Obama
gave we saw conservative author Monica
Crowley just bail from her selection as
senior communications officer for the
Trump administration after it was
revealed that she had plagiarized not
only parts of her 2012 book but also
columns she wrote for the Washington
Times parts of her tooth
and PhD dissertation for Columbia
University as President George W Bush
once said and he said it really
eloquently really important question
about education and children here is
where my mind went
as I read about Betsy DeVos is
plagiarism remember this is our children
learning as yesterday's positive report
card shows children's do learn yes
when standards are high and results are
measured that's right
children's do learn pat when standards
are high hiring a plagiarize er to run
the country's Education Department is
not exactly the high standards that the
standards that will lead to children's
learning as our fearless former
president said yeah this is pretty bad
but I think it would have been even
worse on her if she had to undergo a
second round of questioning Democrats I
mean she would have had to talk more
about grizzly bears and take questions
from people like Bernie Sanders
Elizabeth Warren Al Franken it would
have been worse I think in all
seriousness I don't know if it would
have been worse because getting caught
plagiarizing your answers for Senate
confirmation is pretty damn bad yeah but
there's no video clips of it I mean
those clips were trending all over the
Internet yeah maybe all right they were
embarrassing her maybe she is better off
copying answers on paper and not having
to answer more questions from Tim Kaine
who absolutely destroyed her al Frank
and I think also do ya Elizabeth Warren
participated in it was a mess
getting clobbered yeah I've never seen
anything like it